cette station est déjà accaparée par un
groupe d'une dizaine d'individus il
s'approprie une des pompes et
remplissent ainsi des bidons jusqu'à
l'épuisement des cuves ces réseaux
parfois très organisés payent le
carburant et le revendre ensuite plus
cher à la sauvette ou bien via des
réseaux sociaux à Créteil 4 individus
ont été placés en garde à vue ils
avaient rempli 5 ans litres de carburant
et tenté de le revendre 3,50 € le litre
les auteurs de ces faits en cours
jusqu'à 6 mois de prison et 3750 euros
d'amende
on va recevoir Mehdi un des influenceurs
qui a décidé de revendre du carburant
sur les réseaux sociaux il va nous en
dire plus sur son business on a récupéré
quelques vidéos sur son compte snapchat
regardez vous allez me dire ce que vous
en pensez ce que c'est malin ou est-ce
que vous trouvez ça et inadmissible
c'est parti
comme Nesta les frères c'est full full
full venez
avec nous merci Mehdi d'être là merci
alors eh Mehdi déjà courageux de venir à
chaque fois
et il va nous raconter un petit peu son
business mais dis donc toi tu t'es dit
bah tiens c'est la merde pourquoi je
profiterai pas de ça pour faire de
l'oseille non mais tu dis la vérité bien
sûr je résume c'est ça c'est ça donc
comment tu t'es tu t'es dit je vais
vendre de l'essence sur snap j'ai
beaucoup de personnes qui avaient qui
n'avaient plus d'essence du tout parce
que moi de base je suis dépanneur
d'accord du coup j'ai eu beaucoup de
d'appels et tout du coup j'ai essayé
j'ai décidé de d'engager deux de chez
moi un qui est ravitaille et un qui fait
des livraisons dans tout Paris mais les
mecs moi j'aimerais savoir alors d'abord
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne là-dedans
mais qu'est-ce qui vous gêne après vous
après vous nous dites
pas l'heure Daniel Moreau aussi alors
je comprends très bien d'abord j'ai fait
aujourd'hui à Paris c'était une station
normale ça m'a coûté plus de 2 € 50
en temps de pénurie en temps de guerre
il faut se débrouiller
tu dis des bêtises là tu peux je parle
pas je peux finir c'est chiant non mais
sérieux fais une minute 17
[Rires]
qui ont besoin de carburant il est vend
3 €, voilà il rend service c'est pas
dramatique il y en a qui fournissent des
boissons des des trucs dans la rue oui
mais bon alors voilà
peu importe oui effectivement moi je
pourrais profiter des amis ce qu'il est
en train de faire cette vidéo des cuves
pour toutes les personnes qui n'ont pas
d'argent pour le revendre à des gens qui
eux ont les moyens de passer à 100 € 50
ce qu'on peut aller moins de 3,50 € non
seulement ils font la queue mais quand
ils arrivent deux fois tu fais là on me
dit c'est vide la pièce
alors il y a des gens qui disent ça donc
qu'est-ce que tu leur réponds c'est pas
ça du tout que il y a des gens qui fasse
ça que directement
ou que moi je leur livre il va avoir
autant d'essence qui va être enlevé on
est d'accord c'est juste j'enlève la
circulation il y a des gens qui sont
handicapés qui n'ont pas de de moyens de
venir jusqu'à la station essence du coup
moi je jure pourquoi
handicapé aux gens qui peuvent pas se
déplacer bah je vends le service aux
gens bien sûr mais c'est la main
d'oeuvre que tu factures plus chiant
exactement alors d'abord Gilles Verdez
moi ce qui me gêne mon cher Amélie c'est
que c'est complètement illégal et vous
êtes hors la loi et je comprends pas que
on vous laisse continuer parce que très
franchement vous risquez la prison vous
risquez une forte amende je te dis
barre-toi vite parce qu'il y a le
ministre de l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
il emploie des mots forts il y a des
gens qui profitent des profiteurs de
crise ou des profiteurs de guerre
c'est à la fois illégal et amoral
franchement je suis choqué Macron il
profite bien de de la guerre en Ukraine
pour augmenter le prix de l'essence mais
nous on est bloqué à 30 euros la pompe
pourquoi pas toi vous êtes pas le
gouvernement oui j'ai vu ça
toi tu penses que tu veux bah je viens
avec ma dépanneuse elle a besoin de 200
litres avec 30 €, je peux rien faire moi
avec ma dépanneuse
parce que tu as un mec qui a pris 200
litres j'ai un camion c'est alors tu as
une Smart j'ai un camion il y a une
différence
tu l'as déjà
là tu as déjà écrasé
toi aussi ça fait partie de tes bons
souvenirs
non mais ça me choque pas du tout c'est
pas ce que fait Medi qui est grave c'est
la situation qui est absurde c'est pas
de sa faute si elle pénurie de carburant
c'est de la faute sans doute enfin selon
moi pas dégrise mais des des des des des
comme total donc il répond quelque part
à une demande déjà et c'est très bien
qu'il fournissent un service aux gens et
moi ça me rappelle en fait comme quand
les gens qui organisaient des soirées
pendant le covid on se retrouve à faire
des choses qui sont interdites qui
n'étaient pas du tout il y a quelques
mois c'est l'absurdité de la situation
qui veut ça donc c'est très bien qu'il
fasse ça et arrêter d'être choqué parce
que Guillaume tout le monde a accès au
même service là les gens qui n'ont pas
d'argent ne peuvent pas en service des
gens
de queue les autres ils attendent et
3,50 €. ça rentre ça chez vous non mais
c'est juste la situation qui absorbe
vous imaginez un jour on se trouverait à
faire du deal d'essence ça n'a aucun
sens
Béatrice j'ai une question où est-ce que
vous trouvez autant de carburants
c'est ça non pas forcément j'ai même le
matin oui le matin ou le midi aussi il y
en a pas bon j'ai tout le temps en fait
tout le temps
oui et comme la demande est importante
comment vous choisissez vos clients
est-ce que vous choisissez plutôt en
vous dites moi je vais aider que les
infirmières libérales ou que les gens
qui sont vraiment dans le Nord pas du
tout non c'est il m'envoie ils ont
envoyé un message j'ai quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de gérer au snapchat il y en a
un qui gèrent au snapchat
il bosse cette société et avec le
snapchat il envoie des adresses aux deux
livreurs
il y en a qui viennent sur place il paye
pas la livraison 3 euros BP c'est 2,50
€, 60
de merde c'est comme les mecs qui
s'amusent à vendre des Muses des
canettes dans les files d'attente des
boissons c'est de la démarche sauf que
moi ce qui me paraît ce qui me fait peur
c'est que tu touches à l'argent de
l'État et tu as une dépanneuse donc tu
as peut-être une société mais tu te mets
peut-être en danger d'abord en
transportant les bidons dans un premier
temps parce que c'est c'est des bidons
que tu transportes comme ça il y a pas
beaucoup de sécurité et ne joue jamais
avec l'argent de l'État cigarette
essence on ne joue pas avec l'argent de
l'État donc fais attention pas trop
jouer à ça
cigarette alcool Daniel Moreau
il y a un petit métier chez les
étudiants ça c'est plutôt mignon qui
prennent les voitures de personnes plus
âgées et qui vont faire la queue pendant
2h et tu leur donnes un petit billet de
10 € ou 15 €, ça c'est mignon
prendre le net moins cher et du coup
effectivement faire un bénéfice sur un
truc qui t'appartient pas et le revendre
à des personnes qui ont de l'argent ça
en revanche par contre merci
s'il vous plaît
ce qui vient de dire que comment quand
tu entends ce qui vient de dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si c'était à Nouna qui faisait qui
vendait
exactement
une caméra c'est pas bien du tout
Daniel Moreau on a tous été enfin moi je
sais pas mais on a tous été choqué par
cette espèce de on a tous je me suis dit
toi tu t'en souviens encore
on a tous été sauvé choqué par ça pardon
parce qu'il y a les images moi c'est
excusez-moi mais c'est l'équivalent là
on voit pas ce que vous faites on voit
pas le trafic vous venez nous
l'expliquer mais c'est aussi choquant je
suis désolé il faut pas faire ça c'est
rendez compte vous profitez voilà non
c'est pas de la merde vous profitez de
la faiblesse de gens vous profitez d'une
crise de ce qui fait souffrir je suis
désolé non c'est pas grande série vous
venez vous êtes courageux j'avoue c'est
très bien en plus de le dire en face
mais en plus vous essayez de nous faire
passer ça un petit peu genre je n'ai pas
dans sa manière
vous n'arrête tous les trucs
écoutez là on est là dessus moi je
trouve que c'est pas bien c'est le
problème
je pense qu'en temps de guerre tout le
monde se déb et je suis désolé mais je
pense que il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui aimeraient pouvoir utiliser ces
services parce que entre deux 80 est à
temps pendant deux heures ou alors 3
euros et tu as le bidon devant la porte
c'est pas la différence et Matthieu tu
dis oui un petit jeune qui va proposer
ses services à une petite vieille et
ensuite elle lui donne 10 €, je pense
que sur un bidon Vincent Tim par litre
de différence tu as aussi tes 10 euros
mais c'est la démarche juste
tu es plutôt content que Delphine soit
d'accord avec toi
aujourd'hui on nous prend pour des cons
donc autant se débrouiller
si les lois étaient bien faites on les
suit
dans ce cas là si tu es dans ce cas là
sinon comme Castaldi
mais dis-moi j'ai une question pour vous
vous êtes très bien organisé c'est une
petite entreprise ça vous a déjà apporté
combien voilà je sais pas si vous savez
non je sais pas en fait dépannage à côté
du coup je sais pas comment
c'est 20 €. plusieurs milliers d'euros
plusieurs milliers d'euros non non quand
même pas on n'est pas il y a
l'investissement c'est quand même
livraison par jour ça dépend en moyenne
une trentaine ah fantôme
il me demande que 20 il y en a une
demande 40 il y en a une demande de 10
il y a des scooters ça fait quand même
900 litres par jour 30 x 30 300 300000
c'est 1800 euros par mois 300 litres par
jour
et combien 900 €, 9 x 3 x 3 9 exactement
voilà au début
diesel c'est 350 mais il y en a pas
beaucoup de diesel du coup je peux
tu as des problèmes auditifs alors
bien sûr déliberrouillard un grec c'est
7 euros si tu vas toi-même alors Nico
c'est un petit peu plus cher
est-ce qu'il y en a qui est-ce qu'il y
en a qui a raison qui prouve qu'il pense
qu'il est hors la loi tu trouves bah
c'est pas une surprise
moi aussi j'aime bien mais
honnêtement vous n'avez pas peur de la
prison si vous êtes chopé vous allez
regarder en prison là
tu sais que c'est 6 mois de prison
éventuellement
3700 3700 €.
six mois de prison et ça te prend 700 €
d'amende heureusement j'ai mis une
basket pour courir après ah parce que là
non mais je te dis en vrai peut-être il
faut peut-être que tu arrêtes société tu
vas pas courir vraiment hein
toi tu risques éventuellement de la
prison pour un service que tu rends
parce que franchement c'est la débandade
en ce moment et tu as déjà c'est pas un
service tu as des jeunes qui tapent une
vieille femme et ils ont 24 ans
ils avaient tapé Yanis le pauvre Yanis
qui sera avec nous ce soir
c'est n'importe quoi
aussi
pour faire des
tu dois aller chercher une
station-service je suis désolé c'est la
même chose mais je suis la première à
râler sur les les syndicales les
grevisses je déteste ça mais on ne peut
pas à la télévision arrête avec ça
arrête avec ça mais je veux dire je suis
la première fois
je supporte pas ce discours je déteste
les Grey je déteste les hommes
supportable à chaque fois c'est
insupportable ça va mal dans le pays on
met on ne peut pas passer dangereux de
dire à la télévision qu'on profite de
ces failles et de du fait que le pays va
mal pour faire sa petite débrouille
déjà
on est on est on s'est rideau hein parce
que c'est si c'est 6 mois de prison 700
€ d'amende mais je crois que tu as pas
envie de voilà
tu es bien là tu es beau gosse tu as mis
du gel tout ça
c'est relou maintenant mais je te le dis
tu es bien avec ta dépanneuse et tout
voilà donc là on te met en garde parce
que c'est vrai que peut-être qu'il faut
il faut il faut stopper il faut stopper
ça oui sur des incivilités sur des coups
et blessures sur des braquage sur des
vols tu prendras la raison Delphine
parce que j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit
Valérie bénigne ça n'a rien à voir moi
j'en peux plus de ces mots ça n'a rien à
voir
c'est la même justice il a raison il a
raison si tu vois tu prendras moins si
tu as tout ça à l'argent de l'État je
vous le dis il a raison cigarettes
alcool essence ne jouez pas avec
l'argent j'ai des potes ils sont ils
sont tombés en faisant des conneries
avec des cigarettes et de là si tu veux
parler de Benjamin Castaldi
tous les restos plus sériques tous les
restaurants dans le des clopes deux fois
le prix ça dérange personne c'est sûr
à midi après tout ce qu'on t'a dit
qu'est-ce que tu vas continuer ou pas
bah là pour l'instant où je vais
continuer ah ouais
bah je vais continuer la France j'ai des
j'ai des personnes qui sont dans le
besoin moyen
qui était légal illégalité
[Applaudissements]
merci
après le spectacle